in a lot of our examples you're going to
see data collaters popping up over and
over
they're used in both the pi torch and
the tensorflow workflows and maybe even
in jacks but no one really knows what's
happening in jaxx and we do have a
research team working on it though so
maybe they'll tell us soon but coming
back on topic what are data collaters
data collaters collate data that's not
that helpful but to be more specific
they put together a list of samples into
a single training mini batch
for some tasks the data collater can be
very straightforward
for example when you're doing sequence
classification
all you really need from your data
collater is that it pads your samples to
the same length and concatenates them
into a single tensor
but for other workflows data collaters
can be quite complex as they handle some
of the pre-processing needed for that
particular task
so when you want to use a data collator
for pi torch users you usually pass the
data collatera to your trainer object
in tensorflow it's a bit different the
easiest way to use a data collater is to
pass it to the 2tf dataset method of
your dataset and this will give you a
tensorflow tfdata.dataset
that you can then pass to model.fit
you'll see these approaches used in the
examples and notebooks throughout this
course
also note that all of our collaterals
take a return tensors argument you can
set this to pt to get pi torch tensors
tf to get tensorflow tensors or np to
get numpy arrays
for backward compatibility reasons the
default value is pt
so pi torch users don't even have to set
this argument most of the time and so as
a result they're often totally unaware
that this argument even exists
we can learn something from this which
is that the beneficiaries of privilege
are often the ones most blind to its
existence
but okay coming back let's see how
some specific data colliders work in
action
although again remember if none of the
built-in data collaterals do what you
need you can always write your own and
they're often quite short
so first we'll see the basic data
collaters these are
default data collater and data collater
with padding these are the ones you
should use if your labels are
straightforward and your data doesn't
need any special processing before being
ready for training
and note that because different models
have different padding tokens
data collater with padding will need
your model's tokenizer so it knows how
to pad sequences properly
the default data collator doesn't need a
tokenizer to work but it will as a
result throw an error unless all of your
sequences are the same length so you
should be aware of that
moving on though
a lot of the other data collaters aside
from the basic two are they're usually
designed to handle one specific task
and so i'm going to show you a couple
here these are data collater for token
classification and data collater for
seek to seek and the reason these tasks
need special collaters is because their
labels are variable in length
in token classification there's one
label for each token and so the length
of the labels is the length of the
sequence
while in seek to seek the labels are a
sequence of tokens that can be variable
length that can be very different from
the length of the input sequence
so in both of these cases we handle
collating that batch
by padding the labels as well
as you can see here in this example
so
inputs and labels will need to be padded
if we want to join
samples of variable length into the same
mini batch that's always the case across
all data collaters and that's exactly
what these data collators will do for us
in the you know for these particular
tasks
so there's one final data collector i
want to show you as well just in this
lecture and that's the data collater for
language modeling so it's very important
and it's firstly because language models
are just so foundational to do for
everything we do with nlp these days
but secondly because it has two modes
that do two very different things
so you choose which mode you want with
the mlm argument set it to true for
masked language modeling and set it to
false for causal language modeling
so collating data for causal language
modeling is actually quite
straightforward the model is just making
predictions for what token comes next
and so your labels are more or less just
a copy of your inputs and the collateral
will handle that and ensure that the
inputs and labels are padded correctly
when you set mlm to true though
you get a very quite different behavior
that's different from any other data
collater and that's because setting mlm
to true means masked language modeling
and that means the labels need to be
you know the inputs need to be masked
so what does that look like
so recall that in masked language
modeling the model is not predicting the
next word instead we randomly mask out
some tokens and the model predicts all
of them at once it tries to kind of fill
in the blanks for those masked tokens
but the process of random masking is
surprisingly complex
if we follow the protocol from the
original bert paper we need to replace
some tokens with a mask token some other
tokens with a random token and then we
keep a third set of tokens unchanged
this is not the lecture to go into you
know the specifics of that or why we do
it
you know you can always check out the
original bert paper if you're curious
it's well written it's easy to
understand
the main thing to know here is that it
can be a real pain and quite complex to
implement that yourself
but the data collater for language
modelling will do it for you when you
set mlm to true and that's an example of
the more intricate uh pre-processing
that some of our data collaterals do
and that's it
so this covers the most commonly used
data colliders and the tasks they're
used for and hopefully now you'll know
when to use data colliders and which one
to choose
when you have for your specific task